So back to the story of Jacob and his
ladder so that I can come again to my
father's house in peace.
Then shall the Lord be
my God and this stone,
which I've said for a
pillar shall be God's house.
And of all that that thou shalt give me,
I will surely give the 10th unto the,
so that's,
that's also an echo,
I would say,
of the obligation of those who climb the
power hierarchy hierarchy to attend to
those who are at the bottom.
Right?
Because if you think about the tie
thing as a form of wealth distribution,
which is essentially what it is,
the part of the ethic that defines the
proper moral endeavor that's related to
that center is not to advance yourself
at the expense of the entire community.
So if you're,
if you're fortunate enough
so that you can rise in,
in authority and Power and competence
within the confines of a community,
you still have a obligation
to maintain the structure,
maintain and further the structure of
the community within which you rose.
And that's obvious,
right?
Because if people didn't do that,
after a couple of generations,
the whole thing would fall apart.
So you know,
you,
it's,
it's not reasonable to destroy
the game that you're winning.
It's reasonable to strengthen
And so that's another thing because that
also describes the ethic that should
allow you to be an active member
of the community around which that,
that gathers around that center.
So,
so,
so one of the things I've learned
about the hero mythology that I really,
really like his,
so you see this pretty clearly
in the figure of Christ,
but because two things are conjoined in,
in that story,
but Christ is also the here,
there's two kinds of heroes.
Hey,
there's the hero that goes out into chaos
and confronts the dragon of chaos and
gathers the,
the treasure as a consequence and
then shares it with the community.
That's,
that's,
that's one.
The other form of hero is the hero who
stands up against the corrupt state and
rattles the foundation of the state,
has it collapse and then reconstruct it.
Right?
So because the two great
dangers to human beings are
protected exposure to the catastrophes
of the natural world and subjugation to
tyranny,
right?
Those are the two major dangerous.
And so a hero is their ultimate hero
is the person who reconstructs the
structure of the state by using the
information that he gathered by going out
into the unknown that unites them both.
And so what that means,
here's the,
here's the rub as far as I can tell.
So a structure,
a center has to risks associated with it.
One is that it will degenerate into chaos.
And the other is that we'll rigidified
into and it'll degenerate into chaos even
if it just stays doing what it's doing.
So if it just does exactly what
it's doing and it doesn't change,
it will degenerate because things change.
And if it doesn't change to keep up,
then it gets farther and farther
away from the environment and it'll
precipitously collapse.
And so,
and then if it just changes willy nilly
so that nobody can establish a stable
centralize a game than a degenerates
into chaos immediately and no one can get
along.
So there's a rule for being longing to
the community and the rule has to be two
that you have to act in a manner that
sustains and that sustains the community
and increases its competence.
That's the fundamental moral
obligation for belonging.
And while an obviously so,
right,
because why would you belong to a,
why would you walk into a
club House that was on fire?
Like that's just not smart,
right?
If you're going to be part of the game,
if you've decided that being
part of the game is worthwhile,
you've also taken on the moral.
You've also decided,
even if you didn't notice it,
that you have to work to support that
game because by deciding to play that
game,
you've said that it's valuable.
And if it's valuable,
then obviously you should work to
sustain and expand it because that's the
definition of having a relationship
with something that's valuable.
And so that's the criteria for
membership in the community.
And that's partly why,
if you regard the cross,
say as the symbol of voluntary suffering,
suffering,
excepted voluntarily,
something like that,
which is means that there's
another element of that too.
That's worth thinking about.
So you know,
the reason that came gets so out of hand
is because he's suffering and he won't
accept it.
He certainly won't accept
responsibility for it.
He's angry and bitter
about it and no wonder,
right?
I mean,
we have to be realistic
about these sorts of things.
They're your guys,
all of you people are going to suffer
at some point in your life to the point
where you're angry and bitter about it.
I mean,
there's just absolutely
no doubt about that.
And you're even going to think,
well,
it's no bloody wonder that
I'm angry and bitter about it.
Everyone would be,
and things are so god awful that there's
no excuse for them to even exist.
And like that's a powerful argument.
Although I think it's
ultimately self-defeating.
Well that's kind of what
the story of Cain and Abel,
that's kind of what the
story of Cain and Abel,
what would you say?
That's the moral of the story
of Cain enable essentially.
So what that means instead is that even
under those conditions of relatively
intense suffering,
you have to accept it voluntarily because
otherwise it turns you against being
and then you start to act in this terrible
manner that makes everything worse.
And it seems to me that there's
a contradiction in that if,
if the reason you're complaining
is that things are bad,
then it isn't reasonable for you to
act in a manner that makes them worse.
Right.
I mean,
even if it's no wonder
that people do that,
but it's a degenerating game.
And so that's,
so the idea,
part of the idea of the cross and the
suffering that it represents is that if
you could accept that voluntarily,
regardless of its intensity,
then you won't become embittered and
resentful and vengeful to the point where
you pose a danger to the
stability of the community.
So,
or to your own stability for that matter,
cause it's,
you know,
it might be your own stability,
the stability of your family,
the stability of the community
and the stability of the world.
It might be all of that.
And increasingly I
think it is all of that.
So.